what do you remember about that I mean  Dennis Quaid across from you what was  that like  um I was just so excited that day I I  feel like when I was younger and acting  I had no nerves at all whatsoever and I  think as you get older and then you get  on set like I get really nervous every  day the first day of shooting now yeah  it's like it's good nerves but then I  had no nerves  do you when when you look back I think  we all do this you look at pictures of  yourself as like a little kid you know I  always think God I wish I could tell  little Ross something what do you wish  you could tell to Lindsay  um slow down  oh girl  I got it because I think when you're  young and you get excited about things  you move too fast you forget to just  take a minute so that's what I would  tell myself